what this is
my question for you going back to that
crappy bar and people pitching you
is is there do you like with clubhouse
do you see
competitors do you think it's possible
that another
perhaps more decentralized or another
kind of social media will emerge that
will take on twitter and facebook
and might be able to replace something
if you look at the whole landscape
yeah uh with clubhouse and everything
else do you think
some other company might emerge there'll
be 10 versions of clubhouse we looked at
social networking we thought friendster
was it like friendster was so good
nobody be able to compete with that was
growing so quickly
and then myspace was a juggernaut and
they hit 100 million in revenue and 100
million users and it was like well
that's game over and then facebook
and linkedin and snapchat and friend
feed
and countless others you know so there's
usually 20 people
who will win in a category and
80 of the category will be owned by the
top two or three players
but will those players change do you
think what's your sense oh yeah for sure
i mean if we
if facebook hadn't bought instagram it
would be a company in decline right now
people would be shorting the stock right
facebook peaked and then was sort of
heading down and instagram saved them
and whatsapp saved them so
you know that's another kind of weird
moment in history that they were able to
accumulate that much power
and consolidate that much power
instagram should have never sold to them
that should have gone public they had
just raised money from sequoia
and they had raised 50 million dollars
at a 500 million
valuation and they didn't need to sell
and that was a big mistake to sell
uh they should have kept going and they
should have take took on facebook and if
instagram was a standalone company right
now i'd be worth 500 million
do you think coverage yeah do you think
uh facebook might buy clubhouse has been
uh
oh they'll probably copy it i mean
zuckerberg has no
moral compass or ethics or anything i
mean he's a marauder i mean
he basically copied snapchat seven times
yeah like he did poke and he just kept
trying and trying and trying part of the
reason why the whatsapp founders and the
instagram founders left is they found
zuckerberg so distasteful in terms of
his ability to copy
what do you think makes a great leader
in that sense because
okay so when i look at zuckerberg he's a
great executor
is he a great expert i don't think he's
a great leader i was bullish on
i was excited by facebook in the very
early days
i thought it was an exciting opportunity
to connect people and stuff started
going
wrong in certain kinds of ways and
again maybe it's our human nature but i
attribute a lot of that
to the leadership absolutely and i mean
the guy started it because
he was unable to ask girls if they were
single and on a date i mean that was
this excuse to be a good motivator that
could be a good well i mean it does i
mean
the motivation of 18 19 year old manners
yeah
pretty clear um he was just trying he
had no game
he had no game and he needed to know who
was single so
he could you know at least have a shot
at getting creepy hello creepy yeah you
know he
he i think was so obsessed with
engagement and winning
and he's he's kind of like one of those
friends you have who's just really good
at playing a video game
but maybe doesn't see the bigger picture
in life and um i mean there's a reason
why everybody who worked for him hates
him
and doesn't talk to him anymore and then
actively derides him like so many
the people who sold whatsapp to him
then backed other projects like telegram
and said horrible things about him on
the way out these are the people who
made billionaires
um and they they really don't like him
uh so
i think there is something that he does
that does not breed loyalty
but he's very successful in his focus
which is growth is all that matters he's
a marauder
and taking friction out of products and
processes
is the playbook of silicon valley for
the last decade or two so whatever the
friction what you're saying right now
you're speaking so fast that i almost
forget that you're
you're dropping bombs but so removing
the
removing friction and you're saying
facebook is exceptionally good he was
the best at it
i mean at uber they were like we're
going to take out tipping
we're going to take out the need for you
to take out your credit card and do
payment
it's just going to be in your wallet you
got picked up you leave that's it
and i was like we should have tipping
and they're like it adds a step and
we're trying to have no steps
you put your address in you click the
button and you do nothing else
and so we've been obsessed here in
silicon valley is how many clicks can we
take out of the process
i guess amazon is incredible at that as
well absolutely one click was the start
of it and
then you look at clubhouse as an example
you open clubhouse and you see rooms you
click on it you're listening so in one
click you're listening
and then in one click if you raise your
hand you get invited and you say yes
you're speaking
so it's two clicks to speak one click to
listen
i mean the only way they could make that
app work even faster is if you opened it
up and your microphone was turned on
and you which is yeah that's kind of
scary but that is the next evolution
and what happens when you go that fast
is you get unintended consequences yes
and so one this is why facebook has had
more fines than any company in the
history of silicon valley just giant
fines for doing stuff like this
and one of them was i don't know if you
remember when they created groups or if
you have a group for your podcast
but you know you can just add people to
a group without their permission
and there was this famous case when they
first came out with it
somebody created a nambla fake group
national man love boy association or
whatever like pedophilia association
and they added zuckerberg mike arrington
myself and like 20 other
famous people in silicon valley and i
was like and then somebody takes a
screenshot of it and they're like you're
right
and i'm like no facebook last year and
then zuckerberg's response was well if
your friends put you in that
namla group you should get new friends
and it was like you got put in there too
yeah and then the sad part about it was
there were a group of young men who were
gay and who were in college
and there was a gay choir in their
college and the person who was
coordinating
their facebook group added them yeah so
zuckerberg it wasn't enough for
zuckerberg to
make it so anybody could add anybody to
any group because it will grow faster
let alone you have to confirm you want
to be added to the group what it also
did was posted it on their walls to
increase engagement
and what they inadvertently did was they
outed a bunch of 18 19 year olds in
college to their families
because they joined the gay men's choir
at some college
and this is the kind of way you know
this is where silicon valley needs to
check itself and to do better
is you have to really think well there
is my incentive to grow faster
and then there's what's right for
society and for the individual you got
to think it through
think it through it's sometimes very
difficult
this is where vision is required to
anticipate the
uh unintended consequences and it seems
like mark zuckerberg is not very good
you